[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want
welcome back
what'd you bake do over the yeah welcome
back happy new year twenty everything
right you look so stupid
you need the [ __ ] guys in the video i'm
secretly hating though cuz i wish i had
a stylist left to be honest yeah I
didn't realize how much I would use this
[ __ ] like I was kinda surprised me you
scratch your ear draw pictures and draw
pictures or you like you know like by
quick notes instead of I having to open
up the yeah when you lose that pen
typing is faster
no yes for me to go into the app is
somebody's talking I'm like old movies
for me writing is faster many of you the
minute you pull it out it's a note motor
it yeah oh that's what you're gonna do
when you lose that pen so it's kind of
hard to lose the pen so once you have it
out and you move away from it let's wait
for it won't wait once you move it out
the thing and you if it says you're
without your pen and then yet then you
can you buy a new pen well I've known
you for like a decade now yeah and I've
found so much of your [ __ ] everywhere
like multiple pairs of glasses a [ __ ]
watch shirt I probably have some of your
[ __ ] at my house I have someone take Joe
[ __ ] at my house no really I can't
elaborate all your Browntown
I still didn't take it back but I'm
switching back to an iPhone not because
I hate this phone I'm taking myself I
love this [ __ ] phone it's just
everybody else uses it and when I have
to like file transfer download files
airdrop [ __ ] makes it difficult dude
did you know you could to way airdrop
what do you mean so usually when I'm air
dropping to people that say I'm sending
it to you or whatever the other day me
my other friend were air dropping videos
at the same time and you can do it
together and I'm sending him to videos
he's sending me twelve videos and it
doesn't really clog up the band
yeah I thought you could always do that
I just never liked all the missin new
pictures send me a picture at the same
time I never did that with anybody but
now I'm switching back and I don't want
to give up this phone but it's it's just
too annoying it's annoying me right now
so if everybody else had Android to be
fine but nobody else does but then why
do you send it yeah how do you send it
to Android oh they have their own file
transfer is it okay yeah so you could do
Android and really well they always have
to email us yeah what we don't have it
because you don't have Android so we
have an app the file transfer is over
real quick just like airdrop oh I don't
need you guys have [ __ ] Android dude
did you not know this going in David I
did but then light at the same time I
thought Google Drive would be good
enough but then with Google Drive
there's like a couple of glitches and
that's an app problem not a phone
problem so unless they fixed [ __ ]
Google drive's [ __ ] then I'm fine
hmm so to speak that jackets fire though
thank you I'm staying single cycle that
wasn't us or three to three bro Oh three
to three my problems not problems you
got everyone's break cause we're off for
three weeks
oh yeah I'm only interested in your
China trip oh you are yeah I don't care
about anybody we didn't is I seen
everybody I didn't see you in Casey I've
seen everybody what the [ __ ] you guys
are special it's just that I didn't see
them yeah China is a lot more
interesting than whatever the [ __ ] we
did well thanks for that
that was only in China for one day
because so we were in Hong Kong the
whole time but then we went to Macau for
one of them one of the days and then we
went to Shenzhen the other one Macau
also means Mexican just kidding I don't
know we got more men to Shenzhen
Shenzhen whatever commit to Fagin save
you it's cuz I polish Shenzhen but then
everyone who pronounces it as shinjin
they say like second but then I forget
cuz I called it shinsen anyway
Shenzhen they go they speak man and
Cantonese Cantonese but they also speak
Mandarin what's the main like for the
Mandarin okay but a lot of them speak
auntie is that near Guang Zhou no it's
like more hours okay
but yeah so most of the day I feel like
we spent it in the van cuz then we went
to do yeah we went to this town that was
really far away there's like hot Hakka
village because Casey's dad has like
Hakka lineage Oh took a type of
Cantonese or something right yeah maybe
tighter-fitting Casey's that was doing a
haka though I want to take you to my
traditional village and he comes out of
the [ __ ] village with like feathers
very
all right strawberry and [ __ ] huh cuz
I love it that yeah I know money's
cracking us up in Hawaii Michael
everything you said is hilarious
somebody care about one two three four
five extra funny too because you'll just
be in the background you'd be like he's
awesome I love them but yeah so then we
went there and then after that we went
to this other like small village which I
don't know what it was what's the
difference between a haka village in
like a normal village no so this place
it was like a historic place I don't I
didn't really fully understand yeah just
get it fully explained to me cuz they
didn't even fully understand they just
took us there oh how complicated the
Chinese languages nobody understands
anything Bobby Bobby that be that okay
why are we here I don't know this is
calico
literally what bar tells me all the time
when he translates I'm like what did
they say goes I don't know but he looks
like he knows the ha he's like oh he's
like oh they go back and forth and you
last like whatever and I'm like so what
happened he goes I don't know just smile
and nod I was so frustrated because we
took a tour in Taiwan and then the tour
was in Chinese and then he was my
translator and then he would just say I
don't know all the time on oh wow well
they're speaking above my comprehension
level mmm oh you ever start talking
about like politics and history [ __ ] I'm
like um I got I'm a [ __ ]
five-year-old Chinese language person
you know for Chinese people critical of
other Chinese people not knowing how to
speak Chinese yeah I feel like all
ethnicities are like that okay I thought
the minute you go like you're American
then it's different
oh I feel like that's not how it is in
Korean people like if they find out
you're American we used to still no I
get oh yeah okay then yeah you know and
we started our trip in Korea though oh
really good how do you pronounce that
airport yeah I don't know that but
inches yeah it was like how long were
you there for because the Korean is the
same like the ILO is the same no but I
pronounce the e and in the word ng on
yes I was like we were pronounced again
like in T on Oh how do you pronounce it
it's your goat but that Molly's dub it's
a gigantic ass mom how long did you guys
stay there so it was supposed to be
three hours but our flight got delayed
so we end up having like two hours both
you left the mall I'm you left the
airport
oh yeah that mall that most [ __ ] you
yeah yeah yeah did we were we at that
Airport the airport is in the Incheon
whatever city and then we were at that
mall for a couple of times something but
it was like a few like the electronics
floors like the bottom floor was huge
oh wait did it have like Rolex and all
that [ __ ] in there and we were we're
going to those shops Rolex I think it's
our foot all are doing but I don't hang
out with David yeah I really wanted to
leave the Arab you know did you notice
that everybody in the airport that was
Korean like when they go to the airport
where they're flying out to they're not
dressed comfortably they look good yeah
dressed up to the [ __ ] TV so when we
went when Muriel and I uh we were
traveling in Taiwan we stopped off in
Korea yeah when when I was in Korea I
was in basketball shorts you know but
disgust is greasy looking everybody
looks fly as [ __ ] I think just Americans
when we travel we look sloppy because
Europeans look good - yeah oh really
that Pete coats on like scarves like
they look really good yeah we were
actually on a mission to try to get
Casey a peacoat but then that's when I
got sick and so I couldn't go shopping
with him he and I want to buy one
without me there so we didn't get him
one so romantic
yeah but um yeah like in Hong Kong
though they had such nice clothes like
I'm telling you I got this and this from
Hong Kong like and it was so cheap and
the quality is so good like I could not
stop breathing are you getting it from
the source that's why quality was
actually good that like that's the [ __ ]
like every time we get Chinese stuff if
the quality sucks like it's always at
the thin material the sewing is all
[ __ ] up but this like touch this [ __ ]
this is thick like this is nice I love
it very much
and then um but yeah back to Shenzhen
everyone says that they go there for the
massages or like people from Hong Kong
go there to get massages though special
funny the Airbnb we got we got it we got
in an unofficial red-light district so
there was prostitutes everywhere around
but then their dress I ignore off all
normal people because they do have like
short skirts and something you couldn't
really tell them you look like they're
older ladies too you're like in their
40s I mean they're like straight a
prostitute and then the reason why
because we're probably the best one but
agents at 40 look like Asians at like 18
will they look like 40 to me no no no
baby an angel hey seven year olds need
[ __ ] too and all the Asian ladies have
a certain amount of attitude that you're
just like
dude space you are [ __ ] judging you
while she's trying to make what you want
me to do with what Casey's dad I had a
problem with his knee so you kept
telling behind the group and so he was
walking alone behind us a lot of this
Bible he was just pretty good an act hey
you guys go ahead
don't worry about me okay oh oh stop a
pen I catch up later
[Applause]
they would go around he goes just
perfect oh my gosh they keep they just
try to pick up on me right now and I was
like what did they say I like coffee
into his mind they're picking up on him
different words those are my words but
um but yes you try to cry on my business
[Laughter]
Briana he was like no they're so
discreet they're just like hey come on
let's go do it
what the [ __ ] does three that's three
part is not the way like her approach is
like just between the two of them that
kind of discreet where it's not like hey
Big Daddy but they're not heckling you
it's more like oh yeah exactly
like roaches in like we thought Isaac
about it mummy
my knee hurts too Casey's dead
yeah comes out a foggy glasses
[Laughter]
but it was cute though cuz every time
we'd pass a lady in like cuz they were
always on their phone for like I don't
know just talking to her clients yeah I
guess or like texting and stuff and then
so would pass by one he'll be like mommy
oh I'm like no baby we were in the
different neighborhoods all Asian women
now are just prostituting yeah is she
one no that's just a normal lady deity
you could buy girls so gimme like
already would have bought at all did you
tell how sad it is for their lives and
how terrible it did I went in details
it'd ruin his his spank bank form you
guys get a massage at the shenzhen place
oh we did it but what I did end up doing
was I we got those the fish pedicure
thing oh cool weird it's the skin the
dead skin why are you shaking I can't do
that [ __ ] I just feel bad for the fish
oh they're eating food though they get
food that's [ __ ] disgusting food but
they like it though they like they don't
have a choice they're like in this
[ __ ] little bin they do it in Hawaii
remember when I was at the little yeah
but they have like a different [ __ ] and
it's out of the hole but it is the
oysters because they flatly fly to you
they were eating my peeled skin when I
got sunburned yep they said this is
delicious we couldn't stop laughing
I stuck my finger in there to see what
it felt like they go for your finger
yeah cuz you're starving me that for my
cuticle I heard that it was nothing but
a lot of interesting foods that kept
coming out like chicken feet or
something Casey remembers the food more
than 92 we did eat snake so I was
interesting well he told us he ate a
snakeskin and tastes kinda like salmon
skin but like a little bit chewier yeah
he was like yeah when they pulled out
this snake and then Isaac didn't even
know what's going on and he's like oh
choose one and then like they killed it
in front of us yeah
just chop the head yeah what the [ __ ]
and I'm like damn that's hardcore we
were so proud of Isaac though this whole
trip cuz usually he'll like act up and
he just gets fussy you know he's a kid
but now that he's older he was so good
like he did not act up he was so down
and trying all the foods and it felt
Casey and I were like honestly it felt
like this was all these years like we
were training him for Hong Kong because
Hong Kong is so intense like yeah the
city itself is intense the food
computers crazy culture shock traveling
is something you have to like get used
to as a kid though now he's used to it
now he's like over traveling mommy don't
you consent we were like oh do you want
to go on our next trip with us he was
like I'm so tired of Charlie want me
just give me a couple weeks
oh you're not gonna go and you're gonna
go for weeks dang that was over he's
jaded Tesla for a couple of weeks now
think about it in love with the Tesla
it's so cute every morning we have to
take them in the Tesla to school it's
physically drop me off right in the
front of school mom yeah I wish that cry
was just a little bigger for me cuz Oh
God would you just flip a coin you
rather have the three then what you got
right now is just too expensive that's
why come on because it's affordable and
still but then I'm just a [ __ ] giant
oh yeah so small for me dude yeah big
car two three yeah it's like the size of
like a like a civic or something yeah
when you go a little bigger but they do
smart they were smart about that [ __ ] I
love how salami for me for you it's
perfect yeah it fits you a fan of like
the ethic how big the front looks like
it's a little too long for me it's a big
the same size as a Model X I like the
way that looks it looks no yeah I'm just
so I just wanted like a bit because I
was in it right and I told mirrors like
it's not that small right it's just like
no
are you cooking because I put the seat
all the way back out of like this nice
this is like are you comfortable all
right I guess not cuz like I love man
she has like no filter no innocent yeah
so she doesn't mean to come off a
certain way it's just her like genuine
like curiosity yeah she keeps upsetting
me like old fat pics of me dude the
first time she met Kim that's [ __ ]
funny she always she goes first time she
met Kim cause can be Choi's girlfriends
you didn't use so the first time she met
it she's like do your parents own a nail
salon just to let you know I don't bring
her in front of any of my black friends
just just in case
cuz she was just genuinely curious
because I think she wanted to ask
questions after that
was that her first Vietnamese encounter
no right I'm pretty sure not but she
doesn't she only grew up around like
rich Chinese kids oh she probably had a
bunch of questions that she's always
wanted to ask but she's just like huh
this is a friend of a friend's and I
could ask you for mommy she just she
just like says things in the most
innocent way but you don't even get
offended
yeah we're driving around and then she
goes Oh home with people dude you know
when you talk about how you decent like
you're over [ __ ] Disneyland cuz you
have to go and you turns into like this
kid and you know you were telling us if
she goes like this yeah well I saw that
she posted something and she literally
did what you said she was like I thought
you people think I'm exaggerating on
these stories that she's so innocent
turn this I ain't you're a Disney that
yeah she [ __ ] loved it and so I get
in trouble when I don't enjoy Disneyland
to her degree so for so for example I
have I have levels to the stuff that
I'll do right so I'm trying to be as
comma dating as possible because she
loves it so we're in front of digitally
at the castle and yeah and then she goes
let's take the picture I was like I
don't want to but I'm gonna do it let's
take a picture so I go up to her and put
my arms around or whatever like this
right we do pace she goes no I want you
to stick your leg out I want us to
connect hearts
[Laughter]
and I like the bells like she's created
literally I go I draw the line here
absolutely not she goes okay fine and so
we didn't do it and she was set does it
all draw hearts with someone else why
that's hard to do why is it so hard to
do but you just did it now yeah that's
different I'm not doing cuz it's not I
don't like things like that well cuz
you're forced to do it yeah cuz it's not
authentic to me it's like but it's not
about you you [ __ ]
no Muriel listen to me no but there's
compromises on certain things too I went
with the fever she was with you I was
with that's it hey there's a lot of
stuff that I had to deal with her
[ __ ] all right so let me tell you
yeah I was pretty tough especially when
you're shooting goop you know you know
it was kind of nice at first but now I'm
getting a little sick of it cuz this is
what she does to me now come here
she'll like this every time she sees me
she goes hi sweetie I could put my whole
arms around you oh if you say that one
more [ __ ] time I swear to God yeah but
not every time she sees me and in public
too like we'll be in movie theaters the
thing that I dislike the most this [ __ ]
like that she's so [ __ ] funny yo this
is a chill dude right so when I'm
watching I'm not mad about all this like
macho [ __ ] but I don't need her to
say these things out loud so watching a
movie like it's very sad I'm tearing up
in the middle of the [ __ ] movie she
liked to like this
[Applause]
man listen now I'm like yo shut the [ __ ]
up [ __ ] boy yeah that's hilarious
I love it [ __ ] weirdo
[Music]
[Music]